you've written several scripts before
but was there any special reason for you
to write this one to write Rocky at that
time I must admit my life was definitely
on the way at least professionally I was
emotionally spiritually physically
bankrupt so I had 160 dollars the rent
was 300 I had a pregnant wife you might
say I had quite a bit of fuel to sit
down and write the script I wrote the
script in about three and a half days
and only because I could hear the wolf
at the door literally fairly
presumptuous of you wasn't it to expect
to be able to star in it because your
career up to then have been small parts
right yeah it's kind of weird to even
say small but I felt that is if I was
going to go down at least into
professional obscurity I wanted to at
least have the opportunity to say to
myself well you tried you put your best
foot forward and you didn't make it
that's what I guess you might say
provoked me into writing the script
because it wasn't something that I had
given a lot of thought to I just knew
that I had to do it one time and it was
innate